bom dia pessoal bom é essa zona
tecnologia é algo invisível
revolucionado passada mas é uma coisa
que eu pergunto pra vocês aqui é será
que está se preparando de fato pra só
pela tecnologia que vai chegar
ou será que o nosso emprego vai ser
tirado com essa tecnologia está chegando
é muita gente chega pra mim fala bom mas
mexer com a tecnologia é algo muito
difícil eu nunca mexi com tecnologia na
minha vida
e a gente fica um negócio que de verdade
a tecnologia não é uma coisa de um bicho
de sete cabeças igual muita gente acha
que é uma coisa complexa é uma coisa que
ninguém consegue
muito pelo contrário a tecnologia é o
que todo mundo consegue inovar com ela é
o que se você parar um tempo pra se
desprender com aquilo que você consegue
inovar com tecnologia de maneira que
você consiga se consiga fazer tornar um
produto de valor
aquelas pessoas que você tanto quer um
grande exemplo disso é quando tinha meus
12 anos de idade
eu gostava muito de animes falar muito
sobre isso com os amigos na escola até
que teve uma época que eu falei assim
legal criar um website de animes e vou
disponibilizar todo o conteúdo na
internet para que eles vejam isso na
época não sabia nada contra um site não
faz ideia nunca tinha mexido com essa
tecnologia é uma coisa muito nova e e
que eu fiz um tempo que eu tinha pra
falar eu joguei meu tempo livre
comecei a entender como era feito o
desenvolvimento de website
pesquisei no google e tentei a primeira
vez do errado é tentei de novo é
melhorar algumas coisas até que teve um
momento que meu site foi para o ar e aí
na hora que o site foi para falar em deu
que coisa legal porque todo mundo agora
consegue ver o conteúdo de animais que o
posto e eu começamos a sair com os
amigos dos meus amigos começaram a
entrar e começar a debater isso na
escola e nesse momento eu falei meu é
isso que eu quero trabalhar na minha
vida eu quero fazer coisas relacionadas
à tecnologia porque eu tenho o poder de
mudar o a vida das pessoas
os de caso do meu computador não precisa
nem sair de casa para fazer isso e
depois de um tempo eu comecei a
trabalhar é com tecnologia de fato e
também grandes empresas já tinha seguido
uma carreira muito grande
igualmente que o java analista sênior eu
falei bom jazz em desenvolver sistemas
vamos fazer o seguinte eu vou é sair da
empresa e vou montar minha própria
empresa e na própria empresa vai
envolver diversos sistemas para outras
empresas
então essa decisão achei que era melhor
maneira de fazer isso falei eu vou fazer
sair empresa que estava tudo meio como
assim se vai sair tal bom vôo e depois
de um tempo eu fechei vários contratos
com diversas empresas como desenvolver
diversos sistemas vários problemas
diferentes vários nichos até que chegue
o momento de que eu parei pra olhar e
falar alguma coisa não está certa que
estão fazendo de errado
estou trabalhando muito muito difícil
que estão sendo e nesse momento eu
entendi que eu desenvolvesse seu saber
desenvolver sistemas não eram bastante
né você sabe desenvolver sistemas não é
o bastante para você criar uma empresa
de desenvolvimento de sistemas porque
são duas coisas completamente diferentes
e qual foi a maior lição que eu tive
depois que eu percebi esse erro é você
montar uma empresa é muito mais difícil
do que você tem uma especialidade
técnica porque vamos a empresa você
precisa ter alguns pilares muito bem
concedidos e tudo isso você adquire com
o tempo por exemplo é uma coisa muito
importante que eu não sabia na época é
que é importante você ter um modelo de
negócios muito bem definido é o segundo
é o segundo ponto é muito importante
também é o problema que você resolve tem
que ser muito melhor resolvido do que
existe no mercado hoje
isso você resolve o problema de maneira
que todo mundo resolve conhecer as
inovação como startup por exemplo e
terceiro problema que muita gente acha
que é óbvio mas não é tão óbvio quanto
parece
é preciso saber ganhar dinheiro de
maneira inteligente com o seu negócio
não adianta você é ter um tem uma
maneira que você julga certo
87 fechado de falar não vou ganhar
dinheiro com esse desse maneira acabou
dessa maneira acabou
é necessário ter muito a mente aberta e
por último é mais uma opinião mais
importante é sério você se a gente
precisa validar nosso produto com nosso
cliente antes de montar nossa empresa
depois que a gente monta nossa empresa
todo momento a gente tem que entender se
o nosso produto é gerar valor do nosso
cliente porque muitas vezes a gente acha
que a gente resolve o problema eles
nunca nem conversou com o cliente ou às
vezes nem sabe que o cliente
e aí como é que você consegue ter
certeza de que você está agregando valor
do seu cliente se nem essas perguntas
você resolveu você tem que fazer o dever
de casa primeiro para depois você
consegue oferecer algo de valor e bom
depois de quebrar a cara com a minha
própria empresa eu resolvi entender
muito bem o mercado de startups e
comecei a inserir no meio e isso é o
ecossistema de startups
ele é muito aberto quem quiser entrar
tem vários eventos que acontecem todos
os dias por exemplo um evento eu gosto
muito é um evento de novas obras
somos rápidos o evento muito legal
recomenda inclusive quem tiver interesse
em participar de tarefas e tecnologia
quiser conhecer recomendo muito que
participem
é basicamente um evento de 24 horas
geralmente 24 horas que você precisa
resolver um problema de uma empresa ou
de alguma instituição e no final tem uma
premiação pela solução que você
apresenta lá e eu comecei a freqüentar
muito isso comecei a trabalhar com
startups e desse evento com esse dois
grandes amigos meus que a gente
inclusive montar nossa empresa startup
no evento de inovação aberta no rápido
inclusive que foi um evento de inovação
aberta que era de transporte público a
gente estava a gente tinha que dar uma
solução praia pra melhorar o transporte
público de são paulo que aconteceu a
gente estava estava é observando como
que era gerido todas as frotas de ônibus
ea gente foi bom com o ardor deles com a
maior dor
entendendo com eles conversando até que
chegou o momento de que a gente percebeu
de que é o maior problema deles era que
a maior parte das decisões eram tomadas
com base em estimativas
assim é eu acho que a minha frota de
ônibus está ineficiente
há provavelmente o meu ônibus deveria
ser o ônibus sanfonados mas no ônibus
menor mas com estados eram tomadas essas
decisões com mais informações
não tinha tanta informação para esse
tipo de decisão
e foi nesse momento que a gente falou tá
aí a gente tem que achar uma maneira de
que eles com sintoma decisão cuidados e
como isso entender um pouco melhor
aproveitar problemática é os dados que
os ônibus tinham dados muito
ineficientes que não eram
necessariamente informações com o tipo
de informação que a empresa precisava
para que conseguisse melhorar a frota de
ônibus dela ea gente percebeu algo muito
importante que era como eles sabem se o
ônibus está cheio
não tem como assim não tem uma maneira
sim por cento confiável de falar esse
ônibus lotam a toda hora simplesmente
falou isso o pessoal mais reclama e se o
pessoal mais fala que pelo ônibus cheio
pelo ônibus ou metrô lotado
a gente falou é esse problema que a
gente tem que atacar ea gente percebeu
qual que é um dispositivo que eles usam
para controlar esse tipo de coisa a
catraca em falar isso ele tem que falar
alguma coisa melhor que a catraca ea
gente nesse momento a gente começou a
pensar em maneiras de como a gente
poderia fazer
pulamos algumas alguns contadores de
passageiros que no começo dá errado
até que chegou o momento de que a gente
entendeu de que a solução a mais a
melhor solução de todas também câmeras
biométricas ea gente colocou câmeras
biométricas nas portas que é e como
conseguiu contar passageiros entender
qualquer o fluxo de passageiros o ônibus
era uma tecnologia muito nova na época
uma tecnologia que em pouquíssimas
empresas pessoas conheciam e que a gente
começou a mostrar isso para as pessoas
as empresas para o mundo tiveram
diversos países chamaram a gente para
apresentar por exemplo teve o prêmio na
suíça que o prêmio do bairro inclusive
também tinha o prêmio hardini mãe
então a partir desse momento a gente
falou a gente percebeu todo o valor que
agregava pra mobilidade urbana ea gente
teve uma jornada muito grande em relação
ao status de mobilidade urbana
até porque a gente não é não é uma
empresa que tem inovado tem diversas
empresas boas fazendo novas em
mobilidade urbana hoje é um grande
exemplo disso é é um outro problema que
é um problema que tem sido muito atacado
é o trânsito
imagino que todo mundo aqui pega
trânsito diariamente e como que qualquer
um qual é o problema do trânsito
se você sente para analisar é 50 carros
geram um quilômetro de trânsito média
se a gente pára para analisar melhor
cada carro geralmente têm uma pessoa só
não imagina que 50 pessoas são capazes
de gerar um quilômetro de trânsito
que absurdo né imagina no horário de
rush trânsito óbvio
está todo mundo indo trabalhar quantas
pessoas existem cidades é e das grandes
e aí qual é a melhor solução para o
trânsito então a construir mais vias não
olha que não é a melhor solução para
isso é aglomera as pessoas o mesmo carro
e aí algumas estatais têm atacado isso
de maneira muito inovadora por exemplo é
diversas etapas em que aplicativos para
que você consiga esse trabalho de carona
você consegue pedir carona no seu
celular e você vai junto com alguém que
vai para o mesmo destino
às vezes até da mesma origem e isso
permite que você não pega tanto trânsito
é no momento que você está indo de
trabalho ou você não vai dirigindo um
tanto no momento do trabalho até porque
se a gente tiver 125 pessoas em média
por carro
o trânsito já é provavelmente já não
existe em grandes cidades
outro modal que tem sido muito atacado
também que o modal que tem sido mais
explorada hoje em dia suas bicicletas
que é um modal muito legal depois que
surgiram todas as ciclovias
principalmente na cidade de são paulo
as bicicletas hoje tem sido tem
aumentado muito muito preciso ter uma
ideia é só em maio que teve a greve dos
caminhoneiros
é o aumento das bicicletas foi de foi de
33%
aproximadamente então é com todo esse
aumento as pessoas passaram a se
locomover de maneira diferente do
trabalho e tudo isso gera menos trânsito
tudo isso gera é menos poluição
contribui com o meio ambiente e bom para
pensar no futuro
qual é o futuro da mobilidade urbana o
futuro tá um transporte coletivo
transporte entre diversas pessoas vêm do
mesmo lugar no mesmo lugar no mesmo
veículo e muito provavelmente com carros
autônomos a revolução dos carros
autônomos que está pra chegar vai ser
algo que vai mudar a vida das pessoas
completamente
para vocês terem uma idéia dos nossos
netos
eles acham engraçado o fato de a gente
dirigir nossas próprias casas porque até
lá todas elas com os autônomos
então eu tamanho da revolução que a
gente vai viver para ver a gente vai
perceber que todo o transporte como eu
todo o transporte no mundo vai se tornar
não só mais seguro como também mais
sustentável
até porque os carros elétricos então é
toda essa problemática que a gente
enfrenta hoje com o trânsito vai ser
algo quente vai enxergar de outra
maneira no futuro tanto no trânsito
quanto nas entregas ou seja um grande um
grande fato de tudo isso é que a
profissão dos motoristas por exemplo é
uma profissão que precisa se reinventar
o motorista de hoje daqui a 40 anos por
exemplo provavelmente ele não vai ser
mais o motorista ele não vai mais
conseguir exercer sua profissão porque o
número de motoristas vai diminuir muito
e aí a pergunta que eu faço é com toda
essa mudança que tem das novos empregos
e das novas tendências que a tecnologia
proporciona pra gente saber quem está de
fato preparado pra toda mudança que tem
acontecido agora nos próximos anos
será que a gente tem direcionado a nossa
carreira de fato de maneira que a gente
consiga transformar a nossa nossa
carreira para a nova tecnologia está
chegando muito obrigado gente
[Aplausos]